[Music]
meet high-five come on man it's
high-five you know me I'm a favorite oh
krismo come on in hey fist bump
he's a knucklehead literally he's a
handful oh never eaten another piece of
candy ever again huh high-five don't do
it don't you do it it's already been in
there one wow the emoji movie ah wait a
minute
July 28th look who just needs X Maddie
McCallister what should I say just play
it cool
welcome to the world inside your phone
where everyone is expected to act one
way their whole life how my name is Jean
and I'm supposed to be a man oh man who
cares
my problem is I have more than one
emotion check this out huh huh God
please tell me you weren't laughing just
now what if you get sent out on the
phone making the wrong face dad I'll
make the right face then I would finally
fit in
sweetie you're so handsome when you make
that face I think he's ready now no
that's our user Alice we have an
incoming touch we are go for mess
booting me just make it the wrong face
huh what the heck welcome to the loser
lounge where the emojis who never get
used hang out what's up Papa I'm in
emoji but God have some sort of purpose
here I'm gonna help you we need to get
off the phone and find the source code
then I can fit in let's roll
my Felicia first we have to get through
this fog develops this girlfriend's name
again it was Tina tonight Karen Sarah I
want to say Lupita
but that doesn't feel right now I'm
saying out loud I think you're pretty
cool just the way you are
the bones
my feelings are huge maybe I'm meant to
have more than just one emotion
candy crush did buy sweet never eaten
another piece of candy ever again huh
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once okay son
what do we do after we go potty should
we wash our hands
[Music]